KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: So
welcome to the advanced session
on Building a Cloud Native
Application from Scratch.
I am Kavitha Radhakrishnan.
I'm a senior PM on
Google Cloud, working
on the GCP Marketplace, as well
as Kubernetes applications.
And I'll be speaking with
Kamil Hajduczenia, who
is a partner engineer
also on Google Cloud,
and he helps us get
our partners on board
into the GCP Marketplace.
And, yes, I know our names
are hard to pronounce.
That's how advanced
this session is.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you.
Today, we will cover the ways
Kubernetes applications greatly
improve the developer experience
for cloud native projects.
We'll be doing a
very detailed demo
of building an app
from scratch on Anthos,
our new hybrid and
multi-cloud platform,
and how GCP marketplace offers
open-source and commercial
solutions that accelerate
your development.
When we think
about cloud native,
we think about cloud
native technologies
that help enterprises build
and run scalable and secure
applications in the cloud.
Containers, secure
mesh, microservices,
declarative APIs, these all
exemplify this approach.
Many of our customers,
including many of you here,
actually think
about the way they
modernized their applications
using containers.
And so what we
found is that they
would start with
a few containers,
and then they start to
scale those containers.
And then when these
containers scale,
they turn to Kubernetes
as an orchestration engine
due to its ease of use,
portability, and manageability.
Let's start with a
quick show of hands.
How many of you are using
Container images today?
OK.
Fantastic.
And how many of you are using
Kubernetes in production
right now?
It could be either on
prem or in the cloud.
Great.
That's a great number of you.
So then I'm going to
assume that many of you
are familiar with core resources
like pods, persistent volumes,
and services that help you get
your workloads onto Kubernetes.
And you're familiar with
the workloads resources
like deployments, ReplicaSets,
StatefulSets, and DaemonSets
for you to manage your stateless
and stateful workloads.
But then we asked our
customers for feedback
as they were writing
these applications.
And they told us
that it was really
hard to manage all of
these different concepts
and stitch them together.
And if you do manage to
stitch them together, how
do you know that it will work?
And will it continue working?
Especially as the ecosystem
is scaling and changing
so rapidly?
So we asked ourselves,
what if there
was a way for us to standardize
how we interact with these apps
without all of this complexity?
And that's how Kubernetes
apps were born.
What we did is we worked with
sig apps and the open source
community on standardizing on
a application resource which
is a Custom Resource Definition,
or a CRD, that helps define
the core resources and
the workload resources
in your Kubernetes applications.
This helps us package up these
resources as a single app.
Packaging up as a single
app has multiple advantages.
We're able to provide you,
then, with lifecycle management,
debugging, monitoring,
and even building
out an ecosystem of apps that
we know will work well together.
Thereby, making these
enterprise-ready
containerized solutions.
We then went one step further.
We saw that customers
were using health charts
for the deployments
of these applications.
And so we went ahead and added
a deployer in the Marketplace,
in the GCP Marketplace,
that really helps you
deploy these apps anywhere
on prem or in the cloud.
And so we've now created
these Kubernetes applications.
We announced the beta last year.
And these are available
in the GCP marketplace,
enterprise-ready
containerized solutions
with pre-built
deployment templates.
We also made history
with this beta launch.
We were the first
public cloud that
could support commercial
Kubernetes apps in the GCP
marketplace.
But today is actually
a really exciting day,
because I'm announcing
the general availability
of Kubernetes applications
in the GCP Marketplace.
[APPLAUSE]
The GCP marketplace, for
those who may not know,
is a online curation,
a catalog of solutions
that we offer to enterprises.
They can now just find
and buy solutions, just
like any other
marketplace, but it also
offers support for
management and deployment
of these solutions.
We offer multiple features
within the GCP marketplace.
One is we're one of
the few public clouds
that offer really popular open
source solutions packaged up
in the Marketplace.
So, for instance, RabbitMQ,
which we will show in the demo
later on, or PostgresSQL,
that is also in the demo.
One Google bill-- so it doesn't
matter what kind of solution
you're using in the
Marketplace, whether it's
SAAS or datasets or
Kubernetes apps or VMs,
any enterprise that is working
with the GCP Marketplace
gets one single bill
at the end of the day.
And US customers can
just start to use,
if you're a developer
that's using this,
you can just start to use these
products within the Marketplace
as well.
Flexible pricing-- we
know that developers
want to be able to have
the flexibility of being
able to pay as you go.
And so the ability
for you to really
be flexible with your use but
also offering subscriptions
for more predictable usage.
So if you want to
be able to use those
over a monthly or
annual subscriptions,
which is going to
be out in beta soon.
But in addition, I also want
to announce some new features
as part of the
general availability.
The first is that these
apps work with Anthos,
and we'll cover a little bit
more detail what this means.
But it really opens up the
world for these applications
to be available, build
once, run anywhere,
to be able to be supported on
hybrid as well as multi cloud.
Cloud agnostic metering--
what this means
is that we actually
follow the app regardless
of where the app is deployed.
So let's say you are deploying
onto GCP or into another cloud.
You will still get metering,
so you can price and know
that your application is
being priced correctly.
We also offer custom
price metrics.
So, for instance, if you're
building a CI/CD application,
then maybe you want to price
on, say, the number of builds
or the number of deployments.
But if you are now building
a database-based solution,
then you can customize your
pricing just on storage.
And so we're very flexible about
offering you those features.
And the last-- managed
updates, which is out in alpha
now, one of the top asks.
And so I'm going to dig into
that just a little bit more.
We're introducing this
because our customers told us
that it was really
painful for users
to be able to create
these applications
and then push them
out to customers,
and then not having a great way
to update the feature updates
or even if you want to fix
security vulnerabilities.
But instead of just
doing upgrades,
we've also added health checks.
So we do auto
rollback when there's
auto triggers that can
really push a rollback
to a version that works.
And so your customers are really
protected from any changes
that you may not
be able to control.
We've also added UI and CLI
support in the Marketplace,
so you can push these updates
at any cadence that you want to.
You've all seen a
version of this slide
at one of your
sessions until now,
but I just wanted
to call out why
this is such an important
part of the GCP Marketplace
strategy.
So Anthos really opens
up the world for us
to be building apps that you
build once and run anywhere.
And so for us to
be able to support
this in the marketplace--
so we have third party apps
that are in the marketplace
today that work with Anthos.
And you can start to
use them, and you'll
see that in the demo.
This vision has attracted
many enterprise partners
to our ecosystem.
Here's just a quick look
at some of those partners.
You will recognize some
really familiar names,
you will also see some
really exciting startups,
but you will also see some
really popular open source
solutions that Google
has packaged up
and is making available on
the marketplace, as well.
These are also in
multiple fields.
And if you take a
quick look, you'll
see they're across security,
database, storage and machine
learning, logging, monitoring,
networking, and much more.
So, really, expanding
to a base that meets
the needs of any enterprise.
And also excited to
say that many of these
are available on-prem
today with Anthos.
A huge thank you
to these partners.
They've been working very
closely and really hard
over the last few weeks to
make this moment possible.
You will see some of these
particular apps in the demo.
Speaking of which, let me please
invite Kamil up on the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: Hi, everyone.
I'm Kamil Hajduczenia.
I'm a partner engineer at
Google, which practically means
that I work with
our awesome partners
to build some cool products
for GCP Marketplace.
And today, I'm going to show
you a few tips and tricks
that I use in everyday work.
Kavitha, how can I
actually help you today?
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
That's a great question.
We could have built
any application
or used any use case, but we've
picked a broad enterprise use
case that covers product
and finance and marketing.
But you can use this to
extrapolate to any use
cases you might have.
So before I start, let
me transform myself
with these glasses into
a business analyst.
And I'm now speaking
to my app developer.
So, hey, Kamil, we need to build
a custom metrics collection
app that collects metric
streams from all over the world.
And this data cannot fail.
This is absolutely critical
data for our business.
And also remember that
the US team is on GCP,
but the India team
is on another cloud.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: OK.
So very interesting use case.
So let's start with those
multiple systems that want
to connect to our application.
We don't have full
control over them.
Probably some of them are
going to use some special data
format or custom
authentication mechanisms.
So we could actually
start with the REST API.
The REST API can be managed by
an API gateway, like Apigee,
and it will allow us
to easily integrate
multiple systems together.
You also mentioned that you
want to run our application
in different environments,
like different clouds,
so we want our application
to be portable and have
a scalable ecosystem.
So let's start with Kubernetes.
Kubernetes sounds
like a great fit.
It can run anywhere on premise
and on different clouds.
And, actually, with
Anthos that you mentioned,
we can take
advantage of managing
those different Kubernetes
clusters from a single point,
which is GCP.
So tell me something more
about those spikes in traffic.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: Yes.
So see, the marketing team
runs campaigns and events
constantly.
And so sometimes they
collect new customers,
which can really make the
data spike dramatically.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: OK.
So it means that our
application needs
to be able to be scalable, to
dynamically react to increasing
demands that we may see.
At the same time, we
want to save money,
and whenever the
traffic goes down,
we want to have an
ability to scale down.
You also mentioned that we
don't want to lose any data.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
That's right.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: So whenever
we are scaling or facing
any spikes, we probably want
to use a message broker.
A message broker will actually
persist coming requests
and let the back end handle
them whenever it's possible.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: A message
broker sounds like a great fit,
but don't forget the
CIO is really concerned
about the data and the
security of that data.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: OK.
I wouldn't be that much
worried about security.
We can use Istio.
Istio will be used for
increasing the security thanks
to the different
configurations that we can use.
At the same time,
we can actually
take advantage of
different monitoring
capabilities of Istio.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
This all sounds great,
but I needed this yesterday.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: OK.
As always.
So let's try and see what we
can achieve in 25 minutes.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
25 minutes.
That's insane.
Kamil, please take it away.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: OK.
Let's do it.
So we have a bunch of
technical requirements
that you mentioned.
So let's do a small
system design.
So we started with the REST API.
So we have different
clients that
are connecting to our system
through a REST API service.
It must be backed up by
some component that is
able to handle some logic here.
So we'll have a
deployment for our API.
By its nature, it's
extremely scalable
because it's stateless.
So let's take advantage of that
and attach a horizontal pod
autoscalar that can take care of
automated scaling up and down.
At the same time, we know
that some of the data
need to be persisted.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: Correct.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: So we have
a separate deployment that
will serve as our back end.
And it has it's own
horizontal pod autoscalar
because by its nature
it scales differently
than the stateless API.
So we want to take independent
configuration here.
At the same time, we want
to have a database where
we'll persist the information.
We don't want any
vendor lock in.
We want to have solutions that
will be able to run anywhere.
So in this particular
case, I will
take advantage of
GCP Marketplace
and install an application
from their open source
version of Postgres
is already available.
At the same time,
we need to connect
those two, the front end,
the back end together.
And we'll do it with a
message broker, with RabbitMQ.
RabbitMQ is also available
on GCP Marketplace,
and let's take
advantage of that.
At the same time,
we need to have
some configuration that will
be shared across those two
components.
So it will be something like
pointing to a specific end
point for Rabbit, for Postgres.
We'll have some secrets
for authentication
to those systems, and
this will be short.
At the same time,
we want to have
Istio for additional security.
And this is our system.
OK.
So let's take a demo.
It's going to be live, so
we'll see how it works.
But in the demo,
we're going to show
the full experience, the full
journey that at a developer
needs to take.
So we'll start with actually
creating new clusters
or connecting existing
ones because this
is a very common situation.
At the same time,
we want to deploy
some applications
from GCP marketplace
to GK on prem or
external cluster.
We'll take a look at the
code and we'll transform it
to container images at
first, and after that, we'll
run a Kubernetes application
on our external cluster
and then we will
release a new build
of that application, which
is also a common situation.
And at the end, we'll
take a look at Istio.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
And you're
saying you're going to do
all this in 25 minutes?
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: Yeah.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
I'm a bit skeptical.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: We'll see.
OK.
So let's kick off the demo.
Let's kick off.
[LAUGHS]
OK.
I think we are already switched
to my computer, which actually
shows exactly the same screen.
So, yeah, great.
It's true.
So we're back.
So as I promised, we'll
start from scratch.
So whenever you
start from scratch,
you might not have any
Kubernetes cluster.
So what we can do, we can create
a new cluster on the cloud.
And GKE UI, which is the user
interface for Kubernetes engine
on Google Cloud console is a
great way to actually start.
So probably some
of you have already
tried it, so I'm not going
to spend here too much time
and will not wait for the
cluster to be created.
But let's take a look
at the few options that
might be useful for our
production workloads.
So first of all, I would think
about using a regional cluster
instead of zonal one.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: OK.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA:
Thanks to that,
I will get high availability.
And I will get multiple
masters running for my cluster,
and all of them
managed by Google.
Here, I can also select to have
multiple node pools perfectly
adapted to whatever my
application might need.
So I might have a few pools,
actually, in the same cluster
with different sizing.
But there are also
advanced options
that I may actually use.
So let's start with such,
like Enable Master Authorized
Networks, which will
not allow external
and points to connect
to our master instances.
Then we could take a look at
Stackdriver Integration, which
is awesome because all the logs
from our Kubernetes cluster
and all the metrics may
ultimately land in Stackdriver.
And by the way, in
GCP Marketplace,
our application-- or actually
most of the applications--
already exposed some
app-specific metrics
that can be collected
by Stackdriver
or your own Prometheus
metric system.
So if you are already
familiar with Prometheus,
you can take advantage of that
and simply integrate our apps
with your server.
In addition to that, we have
such add-ons, like Istio.
With a single click, we can
install Istio on the cluster.
And node auto-provisioning
is also very interesting
because we wanted our
system to be auto scalable.
So we start with the
workloads, and we
use horizontal pod
autoscalers to actually scale
up and down dynamically.
But at the same time, we might
think about scaling the nodes
on which our cluster operates.
So additional VM
instances might be
created automatically, or even
right sizing might happen.
So the size of the individual
VM instances might change.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
So you can really
design your entire cluster
right here from within the CY.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: Yep.
It's so powerful.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: Nice.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: OK.
But this use case is not
that very interesting.
And I think everyone is
waiting for connecting
external clusters.
And by the way, I
already have one.
So let's take advantage of that.
I switched to my
terminal because here I
have some connectivity
with an external cluster.
Let's see if it actually works.
So I will maybe get the list
of nodes from that cluster
and see if we have connection.
Yeah.
Houston, it works.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: Nice.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: Great.
So we have two nodes that
are created on another cloud.
We would like to connect
that cluster to GKE UI
and start managing
that cluster here.
So I have a magic
command that is actually
coming to be available
publicly very soon.
And connect.
Where is it?
It's hidden somewhere.
OK.
Connect.
Yeah.
I have it.
It's right here-- no, not yet.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
So we know this is real.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA:
Yeah, definitely.
As always.
Connect.
And-- almost there,
almost there.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
So what you've done here
is you've created a
cluster on another cloud
and which many of you
may already have, right?
You're already running
Kubernetes on clusters
that are not on GCP.
And what Kamil is
going to show us here
is you can have this running
cluster that you can then
use to connect either from the
cluster using your terminal,
connect it to GKE
or from GKE itself.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: Exactly.
This is what we are going to do.
As always, network
works so slowly.
So once again I will take
advantage of that setup
that I've already prepared.
I need a bunch of--
most probably here.
OK, great.
And now, maybe.
Connect, once again.
Connect.
MG cloud at first.
Alpha.
Which I called alpha.
Yes.
I got it.
It's back.
[APPLAUSE]
Live demos.
Always happening on stage.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
Can you tell us
what was happening there?
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: Yes.
Sure.
So, actually, this time I'm
installing an additional agent
to our Kubernetes cluster.
And it will allow GKE to handle
that cluster from GKE UI.
So we'll have live
connection between those two.
Let's see.
It looks like our job succeeded.
So let's come back to GKE UI and
refresh the list of clusters.
And, yeah.
It's there.
Awesome.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: Awesome.
So what you did here
was using the terminal
to run commands that will help
you connect the cluster to GKE.
Now, you're able to see from
within GKE not just clusters
that are running on
GCP, but clusters that
are running on other clouds.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: Exactly.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: Awesome.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: And as you
can see, the list of nodes
is exactly the same as I had in
my terminal just a minute ago.
So let's move farther
with that configuration.
Once we have this external
cluster connected here,
maybe we could actually try
to deploy an application here.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: Yes.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: OK.
So I moved to the
application screen.
This is a nice list
of applications that
are installed to my cluster.
Right now, I don't have any.
So let's start with
deploying the very first one.
I clicked on the Deploy
from Marketplace button,
which actually opened up
the catalog of applications
available for
Kubernetes clusters.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
So I just want
to call out here is what we
we're pretty deeply integrated
from a Marketplace
perspective into GCP services.
So you saw where
Kamil didn't have
to leave the GKE UI to
go find the marketplace
app that he wants to deploy.
It happens right
there in context.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: Exactly.
So now I'm in a configuration
screen, and as you can see,
I can select a cluster to which
my deployment will happen.
And my external cluster is
already here, so, great.
Now, I may select a namespace
to which I will deploy that app.
So I can also
customize the name,
it will also become a
prefix for all the resources
that will be created.
I just changed the size
to just two replicas
to show that it is actually a
cluster, but at the same time,
not to spend too
much time in waiting.
And let's hit the Deploy button.
What is happening?
We move to the application
installation screen
and we see some progress.
I think we are going to see
a more detailed information.
OK.
Yeah.
It's here.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: Awesome.
So you just deployed
RabbitMQ, which
he procured from the marketplace
onto that external cluster
that he's now
managing through GKE.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA:
So you mentioned
Kubernetes applications.
Kubernetes applications
are a great way
of managing multiple
resources that
form a single
installation, like RabbitMQ
in this particular case.
We don't only get the
list of all the resources
that formed my RabbitMQ
cluster, but we can also
see some additional
information like here, probably
a password--
I wouldn't check
this right now--
and a username.
I could use it for logging in.
So in the meantime, I would
just take a quick look
at the service because
by default it was private
and we could see one more
feature that is currently
offered and let's click
on the Edit button.
And I actually want to
change the cluster IP
type of the service
to load balancer.
I want to make the service
available publicly.
So let's hit Save.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
The other advantage
with having RabbitMQ
be in Kubernetes app is
that UI you just saw, where we
were able to pull information
from the configs and be able
to show you the secrets right
there from within the
UI, rather than you
having to dig through a bunch
of config files, that was made
possible because of the work
we've done in packaging these
into a single app.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: OK.
And what you can see right
now, we automatically
integrated with load balancer
working on another cloud,
and we get a public end pointer.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
That's amazing.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: So let's
give Rabbit a few minutes
to actually finish
the installation.
We can see that one of the pods
is already being scheduled.
We want to have two.
And in the meantime, we can
switch the environment to
on prem.
So on-prem, GKE On-Prem was
announced a few months ago.
And probably most
of you have already
heard about GKE On-Prem.
Have you heard
about GKE On-Prem?
Who heard about GKE On-Prem?
Great.
Great to see that.
So not many of you have
probably a chance to try it out
because this is still
in alpha, but we already
got a lot of feedback from
our customers and partners,
and it's great.
People love it.
I love it, too.
So actually here, I
have another project.
They have two clusters--
one of them is cloud
and the second one is on prem.
And as you can see, this
presented as an external one.
I can also see all the nodes.
If I'd like, I can
click on any of them
and check some
details, like metrics
that are related to that
particular node or all
the resources that
were deployed here.
So this is fully
managed from GKE UI,
but it is working on a
separate center on prem.
So right here, we could
also try to run a deployment
of another application.
Maybe this time something
from one of our partners.
So Jenkins seems to
be one of the most
popular CI/CD pipelines
already used in the market.
Like its service show that
it's the most popular solution
for open source projects.
And we actually
have a partner who
prepared a curated enterprise
version of Jenkins,
like this CloudBees.
So let's see if we can deploy
CloudBees solution to an on
prem cluster.
So once again, I navigated
to the application screen,
I selected CloudBees, I
click the Configure button,
and once again, I can
select a cluster to which I
will deploy this application.
And as you can see, user cluster
1 is exactly the on-prem 1,
it's marked as external.
I can create a new namespace
this time, let's say.
So this will be CloudBee's demo.
And I can also name my
application somehow,
like CloudBees demo once again.
Now we have the two most
complicated, I think,
fields in this
configuration form.
So in this on prem
cluster that we have,
we reserved a few
IP addresses that
can be used for exposing
a public endpoint.
And by the way, I already know
those IP addresses, otherwise,
I would have to check them out.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
This is needed
so we can talk to those on
prem servers or clusters.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: Yep.
Exactly.
This is what we want to have.
And since I'm not entirely sure
if those are the correct ones,
I have prepared a small
note here just for myself.
OK.
I've got it.
So here I will use
that IP address.
And it's exactly the same.
Yeah, I remember it well.
So I would select
the storaged name.
And here I'm running
the deployment.
Let's see what happens.
Once again, we see the
progress of the installation.
And something is happening.
Let's see the result.
Oh, so stressful.
Those live demos.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
This is happening live.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: Yep.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
And so just to talk about,
RabbitMQ is an open
source application
that you deploy to a
cloud that is not GCP.
And now you're taking a
third-party app like CloudBees
and deploying it to
an on prem cluster.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: Exactly.
This is what is happening here.
We can see some progress,
like logs showed.
So maybe let's
take a look what's
in the detailed information.
So, moment of truth.
And this is CloudBees.
This is a detailed information
about the application.
And we can see that all
the resources got created.
So let's take a quick
look at the ingress here.
Maybe we'll also be able to
connect to that installation
and see that beautiful
wizard of Jenkins,
if it's already running.
Maybe it's not yet, so then we
will need to give it a minute.
I think so.
It is still being installed.
So in the meantime, we can
take a look at RabbitMQ.
And let's refresh the
page and see if we already
have our pods running.
OK.
Let's take a quick look here.
So we navigate to this table
set and see the Rabbit.
OK.
That's always live demos.
So it gracefully failed.
But still, gracefully failed
in an external cluster.
So let's take a look if
CloudBees is actually here.
OK.
Almost there, I think so.
Let's take a look at this pod.
And the pod is
already running, so we
should be able to see Jenkins
in just a few seconds.
We're expecting a beautiful
wizard that should actually
start asking me for
a password that I
should take from a container.
And I think something
is working because I got
redirected to the login page.
And-- yes.
Great.
I can see that.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: Awesome.
Great.
[APPLAUSE]
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA:
CloudBees running on prem.
Great.
So at this point, we have
already fulfilled first two
steps that I promised to show.
So what we did, we connected
an external cluster running
on another cloud to GKE UI.
And in addition to
that, we also showed
deploying the
application to on prem
and to an external cluster.
So at this point, we should
actually switch to the code
and transfer it into
a running application.
So I know that Java is a bit
old-fashioned way of building
applications.
But I really like it.
This is why I use Java.
The problem with Java is that
you always get a lot of code
for doing simple stuff, but
I actually used Spring Boot.
And Spring Boot is
pretty simple to build.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
What is Spring Boot?
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: It's
application development
framework that's
running in Java.
It's extremely popular.
It allows you to take advantage
of many built-in configurations
and integrations.
So just to take a quick
look at what did we do here.
We had this architecture
diagram that
was using a
deployment for an API
and another deployment
for the back end.
So let's take a look at
how it looks like here.
So I have two end points
in my application.
This is the REST API.
So I have one of them
to update the usage--
and this is actually what our
external systems will use,
they will send out data here--
and another one to
prepare a report of usage.
At the same time, we
also have a component
that is handling
connections with RabbitMQ.
And here we have listeners
that are actually
taking the requests
coming through RabbitMQ
and handling them gracefully.
So what we want to do is
transform those source code
components into a
running application.
So what we will do first is
we're going to run Cloud Build.
Who has heard about Cloud Build?
OK.
Some of you have so
what we are going
to do here is use the
CI/CD pipeline that's
built-in into GCP.
And you can easily
define a few steps
that should be executed
by Cloud Build.
Each of them is actually
running a single container.
You can pass properties
to that Cloud Build.
Let's just take a look.
Yes, it's running.
So this is a running
Cloud Build instance, job.
In the first one, I'm
building the API component,
and the second is building
actually the back end one.
After that, my
container images will
be published to
container registry, that
is also a managed service
offered on Google Cloud.
So I don't only have the
way to build a container,
I also have a way
to store them here.
And by the way, I also took
advantage of another service
offered on Google Cloud.
This is Cloud
Source repositories.
So I didn't have to care
about building my own Git
repository anywhere, I already
had one in Google Cloud.
So this is where my code lives.
So let's move farther.
What can we see here is that
our containers are already
being built. Let's show
the newest logs first.
I think it will take
another minute or two.
So in the meantime,
we could take a look
about the way of
transforming those container
images into an actual
application running
on Kubernetes.
So let's start with
the application
CRD that you
mentioned previously.
I already have something
like this here.
So this is a CRD.
This is a custom
resource definition
that was created together
with a special interest group
of applications in Kubernetes.
And here I define
the application name,
I defined some descriptions
versions and so on,
but most important,
I define the rules
for collecting different types
of workloads and resources
already running in Kubernetes
to say that they form together
an application.
So this is what I have here.
And it's, of course, accompanied
by other manifests that I have.
So the yaml for
API, I have it here,
I start with the
dedicated service account
and follow it with the
deployment pointing
to my container image,
and actually exposing
a service with an ingress.
All of those happening in
regular Kubernetes manifests.
But after that, collected
by the application.
So let's run this installation.
In the meantime, we could
just take a very quick look
at the builds.
Yep.
That's done.
So our container image
is already built.
So we're going to run
the application here.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
As you do that, I just
want to clarify that the
audience is following along,
we created a container
image and now you
are transforming it
into a Kubernetes app
by packaging it with an
application resource CRD.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: Yep.
Exactly.
We'll start with actually
running the kubectl command
to deploy everything.
So all of our manifests will
be automatically installed
to our Kubernetes cluster.
I'm using a proxy machine
because the on prem cluster
is actually located in
an external data center.
And that data center does
not have public connectivity
by default, only through
those three IP addresses,
and it's only egress.
So what I'm going to do right
now is combine two steps.
I will unreach our manifests
with sidecar proxies for Istio.
And at the same time, I
will apply the manifests
to that Kubernetes
cluster that we have.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
Kamil, could
you say more about why we're
enriching using Istio sidecar.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: Sure.
So we wanted to use Istio
for additional security.
And Istio is easily taking
care of all the network traffic
management.
How it does it is actually
built on top of Envoy,
so we put those additional
containers of Envoy
as a sidecar to each pod
running our application.
And thanks to that,
all the network traffic
is going through those
proxies inside pods.
This is one of the
most Istio features.
And thanks to that,
Istio is going
to take care of all
the traffic here.
So let's take a look
if our application got
already deployed.
So I navigate to the
list of applications
and, yes, it's here.
It's Kubernetes app and it says
that some components are still
being installed.
But we can take a look
at what is already here.
OK.
We have two deployments, we have
services, actually one service
and an ingress, we have a
config map and a secret.
That's great.
So let's open that ingress.
It's saying that it's
still being configured,
but I think it might
be already available.
So I click on that and I
see a beautiful Swagger UI.
By the way, are you
already using Swagger?
Could you please
raise your hand?
Yeah, almost everyone
uses Swagger.
So Swagger is a way of
defining the documentation
or actually the
standard of your API
and it can be easily
used in an API gateway,
like Apigee to
transform your Swagger
configuration to running API.
So I have two end points here.
Let's see if they work.
So I will start with sending
a query for a report.
So let's say that I want a
report for the whole year.
This nice Swagger UI is actually
allowing me to send REST API
calls to my end points.
Yes, I have a report.
So let's see if it's
also running for updates.
This is what our
external systems will do.
So I will send an update
for the same resource,
I will specify some
date for the last year,
let's say in the 1st of January.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
We're getting
very close to your 25 minute.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: OK.
I know, I know.
But we're almost done.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: OK.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: And
we're actually confirming
that everything is working.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: Which
is a big part of the demo.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: Don't
complain that much.
Come on.
[LAUGHTER]
Let's take a look.
Here, the previous report
was having some huge number,
but we wanted to
actually increase it.
It ends with eight, it should
end with zero after the update.
Let's try it out.
OK.
Everything went
fine, so the message
was scheduled to the
broker and let's see
if it was actually handled.
Yeah.
It was.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: Yes.
Awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: OK.
So we have our
application working.
So just one small
thing that we could do.
In this report, you can see
that the overview is to do.
So to do is suggesting
that we are not done yet.
So let's make it done.
So let's take a look.
Where it might be.
It might be in
broker controller,
if I remember well,
because this is what I did.
So we want that to be done,
so let's change it to done.
And now let the magic happen.
And we'll comment that change.
So git add, git comment,
and git comment, git comment
once again.
And that comment will
say that and send it out.
OK.
So I sent out a new
comment to my repository.
I also added a tag here.
And now there is
a piece of magic
that I wanted to show you.
So there is Cloud Build.
And in that Cloud
Build, actually, two new
builds where already triggered
thanks to that comment.
Why?
Because I have a
trigger that is saying--
actually, I have two different
triggers that both of which
are saying that whenever
a new change is happening
to my repository and
there is a new tag,
it's automatically
building container images.
And if I'd like, I can
add additional step
to actually running a rolling
update on my deployments.
And this is a great approach, I
think, to releasing new builds.
Everything that you
should care about
is actually the source
code, and whenever
you are delivering an
update to your code,
it should be
automatically picked up
by your CI/CD
pipeline and delivered
to different environments.
There is no point in doing
anyone manual work here.
OK.
So you say that we are
running out of time,
so maybe let's not wait
for the update to happen.
It will build out
new container images
and this new release can
be used in our deployments.
But there is one more thing
that I wanted to show you.
So we wanted to have Istio here.
So let's see if my Istio
connection is still working.
No, so I'll just run a port
forward to make it happen.
So port forward for
Kiali on port 8082.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: So
what are you doing here?
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: I'm just
running a port forward,
so I want to forward the port
of my Istio visualization
tool, Kiali, from on prem
cluster to my local computer.
And let's see if it's working.
So almost there, or
not entirely there.
Might also happen.
I love those live demos.
Let's just establish the
connection once again.
And here, I am connecting
to the first proxy.
After that, a second.
The security.
So just a second.
And another connection
with port forwarding.
And after that, just
one more port forward.
Port forward.
And, OK.
There is already
something listening.
So ps aux grep
forward, and kill.
Kill the previous forward.
And let's do it again.
Port forward.
Yep.
Something is running.
Let's see.
Well, yeah.
It worked.
I love it.
[APPLAUSE]
So just one thing that
I wanted to show you
is the service match that was
automatically created by Istio.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
That's pretty cool.
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: So thanks
to that proxy sidecars
that we had in our
deployments, Istio
was actually able to build
the whole service matters
visualization.
And we also have a
small addition to that.
So Postgres and
Istio configuration.
So what I wanted to
show here is basically
a kind of securing your
infrastructure with Istio,
but just by defining
additional service
roles for accessing the specific
services in our Kubernetes
cluster.
And binding those roles to
specific service accounts
or users, we can
define who can connect
to a particular endpoint,
like in this case,
we define who is able to connect
to our Postgres instance.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: Testing.
So you got through everything?
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: Yeah.
That's all.
Are you satisfied?
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN:
I'm more than satisfied.
What would have taken us
days just took us minutes.
So that's amazing.
It's awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
KAMIL HAJDUCZENIA: Thank you.
KAVITHA RADHAKRISHNAN: So
what we saw in the demo
is the ability to connect,
deploy, create, improve,
and secure.
And you've seen how we could
use the GKE UI and the GCP
Marketplace to
really light that up.
So thanks, Kamil, for walking
us through those very, very
detailed steps.
We also wanted to
just wrap up here
with showing you how
the strategy of being
able to go after
hybrid and on prem
is really attracting
large enterprises to use
GCP Marketplace.
And we're hoping
that you will also
be one of them very soon, if
you're not already using it.
We're also announcing
these open source service
partners, which you may have
seen at the keynote as well.
But these are really going
to help us deliver really
popular open source
solutions to our customers
through the Marketplace,
and we believe
that this will show our deepened
commitment towards open source
as well.
Finally, I just want to
announce our newest Kubernetes
app solution, Palo
Alto Networks,
that just announced their
service mesh security
adapter using STL, is available
in the Marketplace today.
And we're very
excited because this
is an example of a partner
that started with VMs
and has sort of expanding their
portfolio to cover Kubernetes
apps and other
types of solutions
within the Marketplace.
We're also welcoming a number
of new and updated listings.
We're calling it updated
because it shows you just how
engaged our partners are
with the marketplace,
so you can find new
apps there every day,
as well as new features to
existing apps that you can use.
You can see a list here of brand
new exciting startups, as well
as very established companies.
And you've seen the power
of the GCP Marketplace.
If you're a partner or a
developer that wants to sell
on the marketplace and
really increase your reach,
please go to Cloud.google.com
/marketplace/sell.
And we can talk you
through about-- there's
an entire process in how we can
get you through the Marketplace
and really help you
expand your reach.
So today, just to
recap, we covered
the ways Kubernetes
apps can greatly
improve the developer experience
for cloud native projects.
We did a demo with
some real-time anxiety
in it of building
an app from scratch
on Anthos, our new hybrid
and multi-cloud platform.
But Kamil showed
you just how easy
it is to be able to go from
really nothing to being
able to have a fully-deployed
app not just hybrid,
but in multi-cloud scenarios.
And we showed you how the
GCP Marketplace is integrated
into your experience
and supports and offers
open source, as well as
commercial solutions that
accelerate your development.
Two calls for action.
One is if you haven't
visited our GCP Marketplace
showcase yet, please
go see the demo there.
And you can visit us online
at cloud.google.com/kubernetes
applications.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]